サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチットパリヨダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
はい それではよろしくお願いします
これから今日のテーマについて説明したいと思います
今日のテーマは継続力ということで
目的に達するためにということで
かなり俗世間的なテーマだとは思いますが
まあ一応いきなり説明に入ります
まあ世に魔法はありませんということでね
魔法で奇跡で希望が叶うならば
人生は楽です まあいうこともないんですね
残念なことに 魔法奇跡は一切ないんです
それはよくはっきりした方がいいんです
特別に何か やってくれる力っていうのは一切存在しないんです
それはこのハリーポッターの世界だけです
何かに達するためには
地道に努力しなくてはいけないんですね
なかなか人間が それが嫌な言葉なんですね
神様の特別に恵まれ 神様に特別に恵まれてとかね
なんとかなんとか神社の神様のおかげでこうこうなったと言った方がなんか気分がいいでしょ
何かの他力で何かやってくれるということが
みんなすごい気分がいいんですね
しかし 事実は違うんです
そんな誰かが誰かを助けてあげるということは一切ないんです
しかし 地道に努力することは基本的に嫌です
なんでいろんな人々はこの超能力やらいろんなものに頼っているのかと
だって存在しない病気です
あれは 私に悪魔が邪魔しているんだとか言ってる連中いますけどね
悪魔っていう高次元的な存在はいることはいるんだけど
それはお釈迦様とかサーリプッタモクソンジャとかね
これは偉大なる人物と関わり合っただけで
こんなくだらない人間どもとはね
何の関係も持ちませんしね
病気ですね しかし これは世の中でよく一般的にありますよ
イギリスとアメリカとかもね
西洋人なのに もう徹底的に神秘迷信にも漬けなんですね
アジアはもうアジア人が神秘的なこと
迷信的なことをあったとしたってもね
どうったことはないんだけど
まああったりなかったり
中国人もね 相当迷信深いんですね
だから人の迷信に乗っ取って商売している場合もありますけどね
祈祷でもしてあげたら
いくらか金くれるんだからね
そうすると祈祷師はすごい派手にかっこよくやってあげたりするんですね
そういう人間の なんだこれはということを思いたいんだけど
なんでそういうなんとかな力に頼りたくなるんでしょうかね
人間同士ではそういうことあるんですけど
それは私が違法やと思ってるんですね
自分の国もよくあるんだけど
仕事を見つかるためにも
誰かが裏で糸を引いてあげないとできないんですね
最近はひどい状態で 大統領とその家族の何か関係なければもう何もできん
そうするとみんなその地方の人々はそのコネを使って
えらいいい仕事を 時々高校も卒業してないんだけど
もういろんな官僚を管理の職位までもらったりして
ハチャメチャにしてますけど
わいでとるだけですから
仕事がね だからそうやって誰かに背任というんですかね
裏で手を回してもらって
いろいろ職業職業をもらうこととかはね
できることはありますけど
人間同士 それって違法でしょ？かっこ悪いです
気持ち悪いでしょ 誰かの会社が仕事の人を探しているならば
この来る人々の中から適任選ばなくちゃいけないでしょうに
何々さんの誰かであるコネあるんだから
じゃあこの人を選びましょうっていうのはね
それ自体で社会システムが崩れてしまうんですよ
だから人間の世界では
誰かのおかげでなんとかなったということはあります
あります が よく考えると
それって汚いんですね
これははっきり言えば
なんか学校の先生にね
いろいろ裏でいろんなプレゼントやいろんなものをあげて
自分が合格してもらうような感じなんですね
やり方汚いんですよ 日本ではないんだけど
自分の国ではあります
だから人間がどうやっても汚いことやるんだから
これを放っておいて 我々は宇宙生命の法則から考えてください
誰かに何かしてあげることっていうのはないんです
そんなのは 何でも自分が働いた分
自分で努力した分が自分が結果いただくんです
それが我々の個人好みで否定するだけ
どこまでかとお釈迦様まで否定するんですね
否定して観音さんを作るんですね
人間が妄想で観音さんというものを作ったんだからって
いるわけないんです そんなのは
人間が妄想で欲望でお地蔵さんとかね
不動さんとかね いろんな化け物を作るんですよ
仏教文化の中で いるわけないんです
そこでもう妄想であっても
あまり激しく念じたりしてすると
頭の中で幻覚が起こるんです
そういう日本の偉いね
歴史的に載っているいろいろ坊主たちには
何かそういう幻覚が見えたという話は聞いたことあるんだけど
本人たちは幻覚だとは言わないんですね
あれも幻覚なんです だから幻覚
頭いかれたら一生懸命正邪と拝むんですね
人間というのは だからこの私の話は厳しいかもしれませんけど
私は事実を言っているだけで
私の幸せ 幸福 不幸 不幸
何であろうとも それは自分がどれぐらい努力しているのかということによって成り立つんであって
人のせいにする必要はないんです
たとえ会社でも 自分上司が機嫌が悪くて
自分にだますることであっても
自分の対応によって自分にとって都合のいい環境を作ることはできるんです
人が自分を侮辱したと思っても
自分が侮辱されないようにいればいいでしょうに
自分が落ち込んだら侮辱されたことになる
腹が立ったら相手の勝ちで
自分がそのもうストライクを丸ごと受けたことになるんですね
だから人が自分をけなしても
自分が冷静にいればけなされてないでしょ
相手が苦労をされるだけです
自分を人が侮辱しても
自分が別に冷静にいる
そうすると自分が侮辱されてないんです
相手が困っただけで終わっちゃうんです
まあ殴る時だけちょっとね
その間至ったら痛くなりますから
その時はどけばどければいいんです
相手に返して殴ろうとしちゃうと
それでアウトなんですね
そうすると問題が起こるんですね
だからどちらにしても
自分が相手を殴ったら
その結果も自分にあるんであってね
自分がやったことでね
悪魔があいつを殴ると支えてくれるわけじゃないんです
私の意思に反して手が上がっ上がりましたと
私は人を殺したくないんだけど
手が勝手に野球バットを持って人を殴って殺したとかね
そんなこと言う？まあ言う人はいるんだけど
あれは明らかに頭がイカれちゃって
配線が壊れちゃって 脳の中でね
病気なんですね だから世の中はいたって簡単に心を病気にさせるんですね
私たちも自分の心をわざわざと病気にさせているんですね
これで危険ですね だからお釈迦様がいかに精神が穏やかで健康でいられるかということを考えておっしゃっているんです
だから人間の場合は脳も関係あるんだから
やっぱり脳も健康でなければいけませんね
だからまあ 脳を壊しちゃうとどうなるかわからない
脳を壊れていない ちゃんとした理性で物事を見るならば
宇宙ではやっぱり生命の場合は
自分が努力した時代は自分の結果になりますから
もう他力なんかはないと思った方がよろしいんです
だから地道に努力する必要はあります
私たちの問題は 努力するのは嫌なんですね
人生の失敗と成功を決めるところです
これはどういうことかというと
私たちはどの程度で努力したいのでしょうかということなんです
だから努力するのは嫌と言ったっても
程度があるんですね 絶対嫌という人は
もう当然不幸の鈍足に陥るんです
努力するのも嫌なんですけど
まあある程度で努力する
だから努力する具合と嫌な具合によって
これをチェックすると
自分自身の人生の成功率を推測できます
各自でできます 占い師は要りません
自分の心で心に聞いてみれば
まあ努力したくないということもありませんね
だからといってビシッと努力したいかというと
そうでもないんですね
怠け気持ちと努力する気持ちは対立して
そこで戦っているんですよ
だから その割合が人生の成功の割合になるんです
秘密は何もありません
神様に特別扱いされている存在はありません
観音さんが特別にある人のことを心配してくれると言ったら
変な観音で そんなのは存在しません
だから秘密は自分の心にある
各自でそれをチェックできる
我々誰にだって怠け気持ちもあるし
頑張りたい気持ちもあるでしょうに
それはどんな程度かなとチェックすればいいんです
それは一般的にチェックするのは難しいんだから
いろいろ具体的な仕事に当てはめてください
いろんな仕事あるでしょ？例えば晩御飯作らなくちゃいけない
一つの仕事でしょ その場合は
怠けと頑張りたい気持ちはどのぐらいでしょうかと
怠けの方が高いんだったら晩御飯作れませんよ
スーパーで毒を入れて作っている品物を買ってきてチンして食べちゃうんです
怠け度合いが小さいんだったら
面倒くさいんだけど とにかく作りますということになります
怠け度がほとんど少なくなっちゃうと
元気で美味しいものを作ってやろうではないかと腕を振って結構いい料理作っちゃうんです
だから 一つの仕事に具体的に当てはめてみると
その仕事に対する自分の精進自体
レベルと怠けたいレベルがちゃんと見えてくる
それで結果決められます
あと 若者だったら宿題はやりたいとやらなくてはと
仕事なんですね そこで宿題をやりたい気分とやりたくない後回しにしたい気分と比較してみると
結果が見えてるんです
至って簡単なことです
全体的な自分の人生の怠け道と努力することっていうのは
結構時間をかけてチェックしなくちゃいけないんです
それより先に 具体的にケースバイケースで
自分にある仕事をたくさんありますから
朝から晩まで それ一個一個について
自分の怠け度と精進するあれ気持ちと比較すると結果見えてくる
家を掃除するときでも
掃除したい気持ちよりはやりたくない気持ちが多い場合は
たとえ掃除したっても
いい加減でしっかりはしないんですね
ただ 目に見えるところだけちょこちょこってやって終わるとする
掃除をして綺麗にしたいという気持ちがかなり多くて
これって疲れるんだ やめた方がいいんじゃという気持ちがすごく少ないんだったら
綺麗に掃除をする それで結果わかってくるんですね
だから やる前に結果の推測できます
やってみてください 人生全体的に見たら
人間が成功するのか この人は将来失敗するのかと
これって読めますよ 大体思考パターンは小さな子供の時からも読めます
読める人には 占い師がなくてもなんとなく言えます
お釈迦様はおっしゃったことがある
お釈迦様はただ あなたは将来こうなりますよと断言しません
あなた そのままでいたならばこうなりますと
ということは 私たちにこの精進したい気持ちと怠けたい気持ちっていうのは調整できるんですよ
調整すればいいでしょうに
人間 何から何までがむしゃらに努力する必要はないんです
時々怠けた方がいい場合もありますよ
だから ちゃんと物事を仕事単位で
仕事ごとに物事を見て
で 自分の精進と怠けることをね
調整すれば 何でもうまくはかどってしまいますよ
だから そういう生き方ですよ
お釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
すごい理性的で 現代的で
信仰はいらなくて 誰でも必ず幸福になる道なんです
宗教ではありません それもやらないで
怠け 怠け 鈍足に行っちゃって
自己反省 反省もしないでね
まあ私たちに文句言ったって意味がないんだけど
いうことをちゃんと言っているんです
私は だから 魔法ではありませんというね
タイトルはこれで終わり
次の問題は努力しても続かないということ
もうわかっているんですね
努力を嫌がらない人に現れる問題です
初めから努力したくない人々はまあ置いといて
ゴミゴミ箱に捨てちゃって
頑張る人々の問題なんです
これは 本当に真剣に頑張る
なんでも この頑張る人にもなかなか続けないということが出てくるんです
継続できなくて途中で諦めますね
そうすると目的に達しない
そこで世の中で努力する人々は結構いるんですよ
でも 成功する人々は少ないんですね
努力する人々はすごいたくさんにいるんです
成功する人々は少ないんですね
理由は この努力する人々は
途中で結果が出る前に
まあこれは耐えられないんだと
もううんざりだと途中で諦めるんです
しかし これから答えを出します
欲 怒り 嫉妬 恨み 傲慢などの衝動でやることをなら決して諦めらないという現象もあります
そこで人間がいるんですよ
欲で 怒りで 憎しみで頑張っちゃう
その時は諦めませんね
恨みで何かやると頑張りますよ
そういう悪感情っていうのはなかなか消えません
感情で決める目的は理性的に見ると間違っています
それで我々 我々はものすごく恨みを抱いて
恨みで何かやろうと決めたら
それって間違いでしょ
恨みでやることは決していいことじゃないでしょ
誰かを不幸に陥れることでしょ
もしかすると法律も犯すでしょ
はい その結果 相手が不幸になった
自分は自分も不幸になるんです
怒りでやったっても同じことなんです
だから この会社なんかで
この不正行為やらいろんなことをやっている方々も
億単位で金を盗んで自分で気づいてないんです
バレたところで 会社のお金は 5億円盗んでいるんだと
いえいえ そんなことはないでしょうと自分では思っているんだけど
それは嘘やと 自分で気づいてもないんで
あれは欲の衝動なんですね
金が簡単に誤魔化しちゃえば手に入るし
それで遊んだり いろんな変なことに金使ったり
異性にバンバンいろんなものを買ってあげたり
自分で金の計算していないんです
それでやがてバレたところで
億単位で盗んでいることになるんです
で それも そういう人たち
しっかりやるんですよ
しっかりやったからといって意味がないでしょう
いつかバレますからね
で 給料は知れたものだからね
豪邸を持ってると 給料から計算してみるとわかるでしょうに
バレることは明確なんです
なんか以外はね 政府の方々以外はね
世界一億万長者になってますけど
誰でも知ってますよ 議員さんの給料どれぐらいですかと
だから  法律をちゃんと働いているこの国では
これはかなり危険なものなんですね
だから私たちは欲 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみ 恨み 傲慢のような感情があると
がむしゃら頑張っちゃうんです
諦めません 結果出るまで
でもそれやっていいんですかね
自分にも他人にも不幸をもたらす行為になります
だからもう一度考えましょう
真面目に頑張ろうとしても
やっぱり途中でもう諦めてしまう
だから結果出ないで失敗したことになる
と言っても絶対諦めない人間もいる
この人々は悪感情で生きている
だから迷惑 社会にも国にも地球にも迷惑な存在なんです
テロリストみたいに決して諦めませんだからね
これから世界どうなるのかと
もう読めたものじゃないんです
この ISIS というのは新しく現れた組織で
かなりイスラムなんだか何だかっていうね
あるいはシリアとかそこら辺ね
イラクとかね 今もう残酷極まりのないんだけど
日本人も参加したがってるんだから
テロ行為に で ヨーロッパ人やらアメリカ人やらインターネットから結構人々をリストインするんですよ
だからまあいくらでもできるということになるんです
空から爆弾を落としても
なおさら問題は悪化するだけで
で 頭の悪いオバマがもう治療不可能ながんを作っちゃったんですね
人類の中で そんなにややこしいことでもないんですよ
民族争い 宗教争いっていうのは
ビシビシと理性的で言っちゃえば
言うことは平等に言わなくちゃいけない
我こそ正しいという立場で言うと
相手が聞いてくれないんです
だから アメリカが何言ったっても
アメリカこそが正しくて
世界 地球 人類 みんな間違っているというスタンスでしょ
だから誰も話を聞いてくれない
イスラム教が正しいか
キリスト教が正しいか
誰もわかったもんじゃないんだから
どう見たってもこれは悪いでしょうにと
それぐらいのことをやめた方がやめた方がいいんじゃないんですかと
この人権も守ってあげて
そんなに大げさな問題じゃないと思いますけど
でももうがんになっちゃったんですよ
とにかくこの怒り 嫉妬
憎しみの感情では 人間は諦めないで頑張りますけど
それ自体恐ろしい迷惑なことになります
はい そのテーマ それで終わります
修行の怒り 欲と怒りの問題
ちょっと難しくなると思いますけど
日常生活の場合は欲と怒りの衝動で努力します
私たち皆様も誰でも人間というのは日常生活の場合はだいたい欲と怒りですね
我々を動かしている衝動が
諦めることなく計測もできます
まあ例えば家族を持っている人々は
会社でいくら侮辱されても頑張って会社に行きますよ
クビにならないようにもう頑張るんですね
プライドをもう傷ついても仕事に行くんです
諦めない 嫌や こんな会社はとかね
家族がいるんだから 子供たちは学校に行ってる
だから教育もありますからね
その場合は諦めず頑張るんですね
だから子供に家族に対する愛着
それは欲ですからね 愛着があって
結構苦労にめげずに頑張ることもあります
しかし 人生は不幸と苦労に満ちたものになります
そういうふうに頑張るんだけど
人生は苦労と不幸は絶えないんですね
会社でくたくたいじめられている
それでも自分にとってはもう家族いるし
もうどうしようもないんですね
会社辞めたっても 新しい仕事を見つかるという保証もないし
その場合はやっぱり我慢して
とにかく何ぐらいだっても仕事に行って
クビにならないようにと頑張っちゃうんですね
それはいいんだけど 自分の人生っていうのはすごい不幸なんですね
ものすごい苦しいんですよ
それで精神的にもものすごいトラブルを起こしたりして
もしかすると病院に行く羽目にもなります
そういう危険性があります
人生は悪に染まります
これに気をつけてください
欲と怒りで人間がみんな頑張っています
会社で新しい品物を開発するときでも
ライバル会社に対してもなんとか潰してやろうと思っても
喧嘩して怒りで頑張ります
で そうなってくると その会社っていうのは人間ではないんだから
会社の中で仕事をする人間ですからね
みんなの心が悪に染まります
例えば 家族に対してすごい愛着がある場合は
自分の収入は本当に足らないと
子供たちがいろんなもの必要で
もうギャーギャーと言っている
それを買ってあげたくなる
そうすると盗みでもやっちゃいますよ
もう もうどうしようもなく
会社の金で持っていっちゃう可能性はありますよ
で それでよろしいかというと
自分が悪は悪を犯しちゃったんですね
罪を犯しちゃったんですね
これは本当にディレンマで
パラドックスでどうしようもないことなんですね
これを覚えてほしい 理解してほしい
私たちはごく普通に生活して
ごく普通に仕事をして
ごく普通に家族を大事にして生きていますけど
心が悪に染まっているんです
これ避けられないんです
存在の罠なんです 私は誰にも悪いことをしていないんだそうと言ったって
自慢することはちょっと難しいんです
誰に目をかけてないかもしれませんだけど
自分自身の心が欲と怒りが活動しているんだから
悪に染まってはいるんですね
世間の流れに沿った生き方は危険です
はい これは世間での生き方
昔も今もこれからも 世間はこういう生き方をしているんです
欲と怒り アメリカには敵がないと生きる勇気が湧いてこないんですね
長い間 ソ連が敵だと潰さなくちゃと
ソ連崩壊したら敵がなくなっちゃって
アメリカ人の勢いがどんどん弱くなっちゃって
新しい敵を作るんです
世の中はそんなもんなんです
だから アメリカ人ならいつでも世界の人類を馬鹿にして
傲慢で どんな国でも爆弾を落とす権利がアメリカにあるんだそうという立場でいるんだから
悪そのものでしょうに
誰であったって人を殺していいわけないでしょうに
人間の財産破壊していいわけないでしょうに
これは世の中の流れなんですね
だから仏教が言うのは
この世の中の流れに乗ってはあかんやと
これは悪の道ですと 仏教的に解決方法を探しましょう
ですから 世に生きてはいるんだけど
世の中の流れに流されないように生きる方法
これからまあチェックします
これからどんどん答えを出してきますから
ちゃんと覚えておいてください
今日 講演はできるだけ早く終了したいと思っているんです
別に用があるわけじゃないんです
ただ怠けているんです
まず怒りを捨てる 怒りがやる気を起こしても断念する
文章はちょっと君が理解しにくような気がしますけど
例えば自分に怒りが湧いてきたら
やるぞという意欲が出てくる
やっちゃいますと もう怠けはひとかけらもない
しかし この気持ち引き起こしたのは怒りなんですね
だったら断念してくださいと
やらないでくださいと
優しい例で考えましょう
将棋やっている 相手が動いた駒によって
なんだこいつは なんか私が負けそうやと言って
相手に相手に対して怒っちゃう
こうやってよしてやるぞと怒りが出たら
これやめた方がいいんです
必ず負けます だから ライバル会社に対して怒り
学校の同級生に対する怒り
それではね スポーツの場合でも
相手チームに対して怒り
全くダメなんですよ スポーツの場合は試合はするんです
怒りはいりません 負けても堂々と
君たちはすごいですね
羨ましいと相手の勝利を心込めて褒めてあげたら
負けても泣けませんよ
その時は 胸を張って帰られます
スポーツ試合の場合はどちらか負けなくちゃあかんだからね
だから怒りでやる気が起きても断念してください
怒りが決していいことはやってくれない
できればやる気だけを残して怒りの感情を断念しても構わないが
それは無理だと思います
で 言いたいことは 例えばもう本当に誰か誰かさんに対して怒りがこみ上げてきた
それでまあやる気ができた
でも怒りでやっちゃうと上手くいかないんですね
できることなら怒りを消してやる気だけ残してもらえばありがたいんだけど
これは訓練していないと無理だと思います
まあわかりやすく言えば
学校で仲間が結構成績が良くて
自分が成績が悪くて もうこれでもうこれで友達に自分をからかわれる
お前頭が悪いとかね 言われてすごく怒っている
それを家に帰ったら お母さんもお父さんもまたギャーギャーと言う
もうカンカン もう全部潰したいぐらい怒るんですね
そうすると では仕事を宿題やってやろうではないかと
で やる気が起こしますよ
でも怒りでやるんだから勉強にならないんですね
だからその子はやる気だけ残して
あの怒りを消すならばいいんですけど
これ結構難しいでしょうね
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ 恨み エゴ
傲慢の感情が引き起こす意欲を断念しましょう
さらに言うと この怒りの仲間なんですね
嫉妬 恨み 憎しみ エゴ 傲慢
そういう怒りに関連する感情がたくさんあるんですね
仏道 仏教の人々は ブッダの教えを大事に思う人々は
そういう感情ができてできて
やる気が起きても断念する
やらない そうすると心が悪に染まることなくなるんです
それでいいことは この感情では
この気持ちでは仕事をしません
勉強しませんと断言したら
それ自体が素晴らしい行為なんです
悪感情を断念したこと
その良い行為の結果として
素晴らしい清らかな意欲が生まれるんです
損はしません この断念することが大事なんです
今私は試合しません なぜかというと
私はあなたのことで怒っているんだと
だから この怒りが消えて
あなたとニコニコと握手をして仲良くすることができるまで待ってちょうだいと
私の怒りが収まるまで待ってくださいと言って怒りを断念したら
ものすごくやる気が湧いてきます
だから これ世間知らないんです
この秘密は だから仏教だけ知ってるんです
そういうやる気が引き起こしても
感情をチェックして もう何て言いますか
言う 何て言いますか 堂々と断念しなさいと
断念した時点で清らかなやる気が生まれてくるんです
瞬間的に良い結果が現れるように見えますが
決して良い結果になります
例えば 怒りで 嫉妬で 瞬発的に何かやってよかったかもしれませんだけど
最終的には結果が悪いです
だから断念するんです
例外もあります 慈しみで怒りを演じることはできます
その場合は慈しみで 例えばお母さんが怒るとかね
日本のお母さんたちは本気で怒るんだから
あれでは子供が悪くなるんです
お母さんが怒りを演じた方がいいんです
すごく子供のことを思って
子供の弱みをよく知って
子供を応援してあげたいという慈しみの優しい気持ちがあって
それから鬼の顔をかぶって怒ってやると
だからこの怒り 演じる場合は悪い結果にはなりません
はい 次 欲の問題 人間がね
怒りと欲だけだからね
欲の場合は断念するんじゃなくて
慈悲に変換するんです
欲がないと商売や仕事ができないとは誤解です
世はそう言ってるでしょ
世の中の人間が欲がないとどうやって仕事をして家族を養いますかねとかね
どうやって頑張れますかねとかね
だから欲やら怒りやら
そういう感情が必要やっていうのは
あれはアホな人間が言うことで
知恵の完成した人が言ってることじゃないんです
聖者の言葉じゃないんです
ごく汚れてる一般人の言葉なんです
なんで頭が汚れていて頭悪い一般人の話に乗る？それ自体間違いでしょう
これが誤解です 欲で仕事をすると失敗するんです
必ず不幸になるんです
心が悪に染まるんです
欲を慈悲喜捨に変換しましょう
家族に対する欲は良くないんです
家族のことを慈しむんです
心配するんです 家族のみんな幸福で幸せでいてほしいと
家族が苦労しないで生きてほしいと
そういうふうに慈悲喜捨に変えるんです
慈悲喜捨の捨っていうのは
あの まあ私の家族ですから
私の親だから これは私に与えられた義務ですよと
だから家族の問題はしっかり見ます
義務を果たします 親に対する義務を果たしますという冷静な気持ち
子供に教育をさせて一人前に育てる義務があります
義務はしっかり果たしますという場合は
慈悲喜捨の捨  4つ  4番目なんです
それには理解能力が必要です
でないと 感情的にはみんな幸せになってほしいとかね
みんな苦労して欲しくないと思っちゃうと
慈と喜になっちゃうんですね
あるいは逆に 家族はみんな頑張っている
奥さんもすごいしっかり頑張って家族を守っている
よかったよかったと 子供たちもビシビシ勉強して成長しているんだね
よかったよかったと喜びを感じ
それは喜なんですね 慈悲喜捨
この 4つをいろいろ回転しますけど
それに変換するんです
欲は捨てる 欲は捨てないったって皆様に捨てられないんだから
この変換するんです 慈悲喜捨っていうのは最高の禅なんです
誰にも迷惑をかけない気持ちなんです
すべての生命の尊厳を守る気持ちなんです
生命と対立しない気持ちなんです
生命と協力し合って生かして生きる気持ちなんです
だから これは尊い禅なんです
だから これは皆様にはブッダからしか教えられないんですよ
ブッダの元の生の教えしかないものなんです
だから 日常生活で皆様の欲を慈悲喜捨に変換する
人生は決して自分のせいで失敗することはありません
そうなると 自分のせいで人生は何一つも失敗しない
慈悲喜捨だったら 自分の過ちで失敗したっていうことは一切なくなるんです
なんでそんなちょっと理解しにくい文章を書いたかというと
この理由は次に言います
世の状況によってうまくいかないことがあり得るんだからなんです
自分が清らかな気持ちで完璧に頑張ったんだからといって
世の中の状況にもよりますから
結果がね だからうまくいかないということもあります
うまくいかなかったんだけど
自分のせいじゃないんです
で 例が良くないんだけど
例えば福島地方の原発があった地方に住んでいた人々は
立派な家があって 農業をやって家畜産業をやって
すごく豊かで幸せで生きていたんだけど
もう放射の問題で全部出て行かなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんです
出て行ったところで苦労ばっかしで
悩みばっかしで すごい苦労してますね
私のせいで苦労しているんだと言える？言えないでしょうに
そういうことで 世の中は何が起こるかわからないんだから
うまくいかないことがあります
狙った結果が出なかったことがあり得るんです
例えば 子供がしっかり受験勉強して
もう OK やと 合格は間違いなしという状態でいても
すぐ病気になってしまう可能性もありますよ
すぐ病気になっちゃって
高熱を出しちゃって 頭が動かなくなっちゃったりしてね
それで結果が失敗になりますけど
その場合でも 自分で管理できない原因で
自分の仕事をちゃんとやっているんですね
そういうことだから 慈悲喜捨で生きている場合はすべてうまくいきます
失敗はしません たとえ失敗したではなくて
予測通りの結果にならなかったということがあっても
自分が悩む必要はないんです
それは別な原因であると
すごく気持ちよくいられます
えーと 生きることは慈悲喜捨を実践するためにあるのだと決める
決めておけば これ裏技なんです
皆様も今日から生きる
生きることっていうのは
慈悲喜捨を実践するためにあるんだと
会社は慈悲喜捨を実践するためにあるんだと
奥さんが自分に慈悲喜捨を実践させるためにある存在であると
子供も自分は自分に慈悲喜捨を実践させるためにあるものやと言って
生きることに関わるすべてのものが自分に慈悲喜捨の訓練させているんだと
だから 友達の間でいかに慈悲喜捨を実践するのか
子供と一緒にいると いかに慈悲喜捨を実践するのかと
親と一緒にいるといかに慈悲喜捨を実践するのかと
会社でいかに慈悲喜捨を実践するのかとか
そういうふうに人生は
私の人生は慈悲喜捨を実践するためになっているものやと思っちゃえば OK です
問題なくできます 何一つも余計な余計に考えたり
悩んだり 心配したりする必要はありません
そうすると頭楽です 悩む必要もないし
考える必要もないし 人生は慈悲喜捨のためにあると
それで解決します すごい楽なんです
楽だけじゃないんですよ
想像できないほど人生が幸福になるんです
何でもかんでもうまくいくんです
目の前で自分の力によって
神様に惨めになっておねだりする必要なくなっちゃうんです
はい 次 このテーマ それで終わり
目的設定 この生きる目的設定ですね
設定した目的がないと真剣に行動を起こすことができません
当たり前のことですね
なんか目的がないと行動できないでしょう
というより 何の目的もなく
ただ何かをやるという生き方をやめましょう
我々結構そうでしょう
あんまり目的もなくて
もう何となく何かやってきているんですね
あれって曖昧で中途半端で
あんまりいい人生じゃないんです
いろいろ目的設定して
着々と進んだ方が 人生全体的にしっかりするんです
目的がない行為は決まって悪感情の衝動から起こるんです
いるでしょ 世の中で結構何の目的もなく
仕事をする気持ちもないし
もう何やこれやと ああいう人々は必ず悪感情で生きるようになるんです
この引きこもりとかね
大学まで卒業したんだけど
仕事はしたくないとかね
あんた何をしたいの？ってベースに何もという感じでしょ
あれ すごい不幸な人間でしょ
それ治らないんですよ
治らない理由は ああいう人々は悪感情に支配されているんです
だから曖昧 中途半端でどうでもいい生き方になっているんです
先を見ようともしないんです
理性で 慈しみで目的を決める
では 皆様方はこれからちゃんと目的を決めて決めて生きてみてください
その目的を決める時は理性で決めてほしい
感情でではないんです
ああいう風になりたいなあはダメなんです
金持ちになりたいなと
そうなって気分がいいでしょうと
感情でしょう 理性で決めてください
目的を それから慈しみで
はい このぐらい金持ちになりたいと
私の能力から計算するとできそうやと
それで金持ちになると決めるのは構わない
だって 自分の能力から考えて
これぐらい これぐらい
これぐらい こういう風に頑張れば
まあこれぐらい金が入るでしょうと
それに慈悲も使うんです
だから金が入ったら 私は慈しみでこういうこういうことをしたい
こういうこういうことをしたいと
慈しみでやりたいことも決めておこう
そうすると見事なんです
目的に達します で 金持ちになって
あの人に見せてやるぞと
どうだいと ざまあみろ
それはダメなんです 自分がざまあみる羽目になるんです
立派な一流の大学に入りたいと思うのは構わない
その場合は 自分の理解能力と自分が勉強に頑張るところから考えて
まあもうちょっとこれこれこれ頑張ってみれば
まあ入るだろうと決める
それから立派な大学に入って
これこれぐらい慈しみに基づいて
私は世のために頑張りますと決めておけば
目的は達成します 誰かに見せてやるぞとかね
自慢してやるぞとかね
思っちゃうと失敗するんです
それも実現できる範囲にする
どんな目的も実現できる範囲にしてほしい
目的に達するためにかかる時間も考えておいてください
いつかなりましたらダメなんです
時間も考えてほしい この時間で
この何年で何ヶ月間で
こういうこういうことをしますと
そうすると着々と動きます
いつか大学に入るぞと思ったら入らないでしょ
はい これが目的設定 はい
ここまで俗世間の話してるんですよ
あの目的設定で書いてないんだけど
あの いろんな目的がたくさんあるんです
人間には目的一つだけでは困るんです
いろんな目的があった方がいいんです
仕事の上司になりたいとかね
料理もできる人間になりたいとかね
いろいろ目的があった方がいいんです
一つだけ目指してそれに挑戦すると
かなりダメな人間になります
これは日本によくあることで
何か一つ決めたら もう 10年も20年もそれだけ修行しなさいと言われているでしょ
そうなってくると 他のことはできなくなるんですね
その場合はかなり欲が絡んでいるんですね
例えば職人さんの場合でも
すごいプライドとか欲とかいろいろ絡んでいるんだから
一つの仕事しかできなくなるんですね
欲がなくて慈しみが入ってくると
他のこともできる もうちょっとまとめな安定した人間になるんです
そこで 例えば一人前になるために10年かかるという職業があるとしましょう
職人の仕事 でも慈しみで挑戦すると
これは日本の素晴らしい技術だと
我々若い世代がそれを受け継いで去ってなくちゃいけないんだと
この技術は世に役に立つんだと
だから人を助けることになりますと
だから人を助ける目的で
私はこの職をしっかりと一人前になってみますと思ったら早いんです 10
年かかる修行時間が5年に縮みます
そういうことで 人間には目的一つ
二つでは困りますよ 会社で立派に仕事をして
もう昇格して まあうまくいきたいと思ったら
目的一つだけでしょ それでもカラオケで歌う羽目にもなるでしょうね
これが下手で どこかでちょっと
だからカラオケも上手に歌いたいなと思うのは一個に悪くないんです
それからもう会社ですごい厳しい科学系のことをやっているかもしれませんだけど
まあちょっと冗談も言って
雰囲気を明るくして みんな笑わせる能力
まあそれもあった方がいいなと思って
こそこそと漫才も学んだりするとかね
そういうふうに目的がいろいろあった方がいいんです
だって 生きることっていうのは複雑な作業だからね
単調じゃないんです 日曜大工もやらなくちゃいけなくなります
そういうことだから この目的っていうのは大げさなことではなくて
いろいろたくさん目的を作って
それに慈しみを入れちゃうと上手くいきますということですね
はい それから精進と努力に入ります
奇跡が起きて目的達成しないので
自分で地道に努力するんです
これ 初めからも言いました
目的を設定する 欲は慈悲喜捨に変える
怒りはきれいに断念する
理性も使う 時間も考える
目的達成の しかし 神様がやってくれない
何も それから自分でこの目的に地道に努力する
カラオケで歌いたいなと思ったら
神様がさっと降りてきて
あんた この薬を飲めば抜群に歌えるんだよとか言ってくれませんよ
自分で訓練しなくちゃあかんです
自意識しゃで設定された目的であれば
やればやるほど明るくなるんです
私たちは設定した目的が自意識しゃで設定したならば
面白いことが起こるんです
今度は地道に努力すると
やればやるほど楽しくてしょうがないんです
だってうまく進むんだから
元気になるんです 喜びと充実感を感じるんです
これはもう決まりです
心理学的に 怪しい気持ち何もないんだからね
清らかな気持ちだから
大体みんななんで途中で努力を断念するのかというと
疲れているんですよ やれなくなっちゃうんで
嫌になっているんです
これがないんです 私が今言った通りに目的を設定すると
目的に達するまで進むので
継続力 継続力は問題になりません
継続力は頑張らなくちゃとかね
これどういうこと？そんなのはどうでもいいんで
問題になりません まあまあ
ちゃんとプログラムは紹介したはずなんです
目的を設定して地道に頑張る
問題ありません 頑張れば頑張るほど楽しくてたまらんです
ストレスはまずない いつでもニコニコでいられる
仕事があるんだ やらなくちゃいけないことがあるんだとかね
えらい元気なんです そうすると継続力っていうことが問題になりません
努力する上で理性を大事にする
それから努力を始めても理性が必要なんです
このやり方でいいかどうか分からないでしょ
だからやり方いろいろ調整することにもなります
ですから いつでも理性で物事を判断する
判断して このやり方では結果が遅いんだと
だからちょっと調整して早く結果出すようにしましょうと
因縁関係を考えて より良い結果になるようにと
それが理性なんですね
理性とは因縁関係を考えて
より良い結果を出せるようにと
まあ俗っぽい言葉で言えば
少ない努力でたくさん結果を出す
日本のやり方はダメなんです
たくさん努力して ほんのわずかな結果を出すと
苦労を自慢しているんですね
ご苦労さんとかね 私の個人的な感想で言えば
ご苦労さんというのはけなす言葉なんです
日本では誉め言葉でしょ
だから人は苦労して頑張っても
いい結果が出たら 本人ももうとっくに喜んでいるでしょうに
そうすると ご苦労さんではなくて
あんたしっかり頑張ったねと言えばいいでしょうに
では逆にアンタ 結果見事ですよと
ご苦労さんと言う必要はないんです
それ日本の文化なの 日本の文化は必ず仏教文化に合うわけじゃないんだから
そこら辺は知恵完成したブッダの文化
文化に文化に変えてほしいんです
だからご苦労さんと言えないように頑張った方がいいんだ
少ない努力でたくさん結果を出す
技を発展する 腕を上げる
能力を上げる こうすればいい
こうすればいいと そのためには因縁関係考えるんです
それが仏教では理性と言うんです
はい 次は継続力の問題に入ります
もう一度 なぜ継続力 今までの話では
継続力は問題にならないようにと説明しました
でも これも勉強した方がいいんです
結果が出る前に断念してはいけません
貪瞋痴の感情で頑張ると
必ず様々な問題が起こる
私たちは貪瞋痴で生きているんだから
どうしても問題が起こるんです
感情は理性ではないので
どんな感情の 波が起こるかわかりません
感情というのは理性じゃないんです
ただ湧いてくるもので
それで感情で仕事をすると
感情っていうのは勝手に湧いてくるんですね
例えば 美味しくご飯を食べている時でも
怒りがこみ上げてくる可能性ありますよ
こんな保証ないんです
今 美味しくご飯を食べてるんだから
楽しいに決まってるでしょうにと
そうじゃないんです ちょっとしたことで怒りがこみ上げる可能性もあります
だから この感情で仕事をすると
感情がいつでも波を起こすんですね
この波によって仕事が邪魔になって断念しちゃうんです
感情でやる仕事はすべてストレスの溜まるストレスが溜まることになるんです
欲 怒り 無知ですね 主な感情
三つは これは必ずストレスを作るんです
ストレスが溜まっちゃうと断念するしかないんです
貪瞋痴で始めたことは
貪瞋痴によって断念することになります
欲で頑張るぞと頑張っても
欲が混乱しちゃってやめたということになるんです
怒りで何かやろうと思っても
途中でうまくいかないとか
まあやめたと まあ欲で良いことをしようと思ったらね
怒りで良いことをしようと思っても
結果まではいかないんですよ
例えば 子供に対する愛着で立派な子供として育ちますと
気持ちはいいんです 目的はいいんです
子供を立派な人間に育て上げたいんです
しかし 感情が愛着なんですね
そうすると結果が良くないんです
結果出るまでいかないんです
途中で断念するんです
諦めるんです いますよ
結構 親たちが 子供を躾すること
子供の将来に対してなんかもうやめます
諦めましたと ダメですよ
あの子はと だから感情で始めると
その感情が仕事を断念させます
しかし 目的自体が必要なものであるならば
この断念はよくありません
例えば 子供に愛着がある
子供を立派な人間に育てたいと思う
目的がいいんですよ だからそれ断念して困るでしょ
もう親の義務でしょ 子供を立派な仕事にすること
会社の場合でも同じことなんです
仕事の場合でもビシッといい結果出して仕事をしたいでしょうに
それが悪い目的じゃないでしょうね
でもそれ欲で怒りでやっちゃうと断念することになっちゃうんです
あの断念が困るんです
会社でビシッと仕事をしたかったんです
しかし 断念しましたと
それで困るでしょ 子供を立派な人間に育てたかったんだけど
断念しましたと すごい大変な結果でしょ
だから目的が良ければ断念は困ります
結果出してほしい そこでなんで目的がいいのに断念するのかというと
貪瞋痴の感情だからなんです
だから世の中でいい目的を目指したからといってうまくいくわけじゃないんです
この衝動が大事なんです
だから私は怒りを断念して
欲を慈しみに入れ替えてくださいと
そうすると断念という言葉が消えます
継続力という問題が消えます
そういうわけで 継続できない理由
たとえ慈悲喜捨で目的を設定して努力しても
やめたくなることがありますよ
今 仏教の世界で説明します
皆様が間違って仏教の言う通りにやろうとしたとしましょう
で ちゃんと慈悲喜捨で今日から頑張ってみるぞと
それでももしかすると
やめたくなる可能性はあります
それは心に潜んでいる悪感情が湧いてくるからなんです
慈悲喜捨のせいじゃないんです
凡人は煩悩に弱いんです
だから 今日から皆様方もお釈迦様に説かれたように
慈悲喜捨で理性で頑張りますと決めても
まだ凡人でしょう 煩悩があるんです
この煩悩が湧いてくるんです
感情が牙を剥いたら どんな良いこともやめてしまうんです
だから勉強する子は勉強を途中でやめてゲームになるでしょ
欲が出たんです 感情が割り込むたびに
その感情を慈悲喜捨の
の感情を持って潰すんです
だから仏教的に調整して頑張る時でも
我々は凡人だから やっぱり注意しなくちゃあかんですね
貪瞋痴の感情が湧いてくる可能性はあります
湧いてきたらもう断念しちゃうんだから
いい仕事を その時はこれはあかんやと
いつでも欲ではなく 慈悲喜捨だと
怒りはもうダメやと自分の心に言ってあげれば
心がまた落ち着いてくるんです
それが継続する方法なんです
はい それだけで一般世俗世間のバージョンなんです
これで皆様には日常生活は完璧に幸福で成功者として生きていられます
これぐらいのことを知っておけば
良い心で頑張っても 途中で何か困っちゃった
引っかかったってことはあります
その時 貪瞋痴が顔を出してます
それを潰すんです 潰したらまたやる気が出てくるんです
そういう風に継続するんです
継続すること 問題になるのは
我々はまだ凡人だから
心の中で千五百の煩悩が寝ているんだから
ちょぴっとしたことで目覚めるんですよ
目覚めたらもうまた潰して抑えていくんです
それで継続できます はい
俗世間の目的について語りました
俗世間ではたくさん目的があって生きてほしいとは言いました
これから真の目的 俗世間的な目的の有効性は死ぬまでです
それから役に立ちません
生きることには目的がありません
全体的に 生まれたから生存欲
仏教用語で渇愛というんですね
の衝動によって 誰でも何かをして
死ぬまで 死ぬ瞬間までやみくもに戦っているだけです
これ 仏教の本当の目で見るとこうなるんです
生まれたんだから生きているだけなんです
それで存在欲があるんです
生きていきたい 死にたくないという
この衝動でもやみくもに頑張って戦っているんです
頑張っているとは言えません
戦っているんです 戦っても結局は死にます
生きることは虚しいもので苦なのです
仏教の真理はそれなんです
何も得るものはないんです
生きてみたっても得るものある？何もない
豪邸を作ったって自分が老いて死にますからね
ノーベル賞を取ったっても
ただくたびれで死にますよ
持っていけません 何一つ
だから頑張ったことは頑張ったんだけどね
最終的にはすべて虚しくなっちゃいますよ
生きることを断念するのはなく
ですから生きることだね
虚しいんだから生きることを断念しましょうと言ったって
それも虚しいでしょうね
では頑張ります 言ったって
脱出するんです 生きることに目的がない
生きることは苦であるというのはね
まあ諦めて死になさいという意味じゃないんです
脱出するんです 生きることを乗り越えるんです
同じことをするんじゃなくて
乗り越えてみるんです
それを生きる目的に設定するべきです
なんでするべきですと言って
今そういう目的がないんです
我々には だから 仏教徒であるならば
仏教徒になるっていうことはね
いたって簡単ですけど
生きることは乗り越えるんだと新たな目的を設定するんです
生きてみるんだではないんです
乗り越えてみるんだ はい
それから真の精進 生きることは
貪瞋痴の衝動に無条件に降伏ですね
生きるということは 我々は貪瞋痴に無条件で負けているんです
貪瞋痴が言うことをやるんです
貪瞋痴に対して報復することが真の精進です
このダジャレ的な単語を作るために結構苦労しましたけどね
降伏ではなくて報復してほしいんです
貪瞋痴に対して これが本物の精進なんです
解脱こそが生きるべき目的なんですね
これが唯一の目的なんです
理性に基づいて生きる意味を調べてみると
生きることは苦で空しいものであると発見します
これはもう俗世間と違った世界になりますね
自分が理性でもって生きるってどういうことかと調べてください
調べると誰だって これって苦しくて虚しいんだと発見しますよ
誰でも 一物人間じゃないんです
誰でもそれを発見するんです
しかし 真の目的は解脱であると理解するためには
ブッダの教えを学ぶ必要があります
キリスト教の人もイスラム教の人も
人生を考えてみれば これって苦しくて苦しくて虚しいんだなとわかりますよ
でも解脱という境地があるということはわからないんです
キリスト教の人はやっぱりこの世は虚しいんだからね
神の世界に行きますと
変な妄想で終わっちゃうんです
ありえないことで 学ぶ必要はあります
解脱を目指す生き方が真の精進です
だから解脱を目指しますと設定したら
その人は正真正銘の本当の精進しています
それは仏道で 我々は正精進と呼ぶんです
正しい精進 皆様に前に説明したところも精進なんですね
それは悪にならない 善になる精進です
善精進 これから正精進
説明しています 次 本能イコール煩悩なんです
それについて考えてみましょう
ありのままに物事を確認しない心に無明あるいは痴があります
誰も物事をありのままに見ようとしていない
我々はあってほしいままに世の中を見ていますね
だから私たちに無明があるんです
無知があるんです 痴によって仲間である欲と怒りが生じます
この無知の仲間が怒りと欲なんです
わかりやすく言えば 三つの渇愛です
渇愛は 3つあります カーマタンナ
パータンナ イバータンナという
わかりやすく言えばでわかりにくいんですね
欲愛と存在欲と非存在欲というんですね
渇愛だけでわかりますね
もう終わりがない 乾き状態
要するに 悪感情の衝動で悪感情のために戦うことが生きることです
貪瞋痴という悪感情が指令すると
貪瞋痴のために働いているんです
これが世間の生き方になる
これは空しいんだよと
あなた奴隷だよと 感情の
感情は決して満たせないものなので
渇愛という用語を使っています
なんで貪瞋痴に渇愛と言うんですか
ということは いくら欲があっても満たせないでしょ？いくら金があってももっと欲しいでしょ
80歳まで生きていたって
もっと生きていきたいでしょ
じゃあ何歳まで生きていたら諦めますかね
こんなのはないんです
だから渇愛と言うんです
ということで 我々は本能に抵抗するんです
これ かなり難しいんです
本能に抵抗することが真の努力です
これは仏道というものです
仏道というのは本能に対して攻撃することです
抵抗できる力は普通我々に
備わってないんです 本能に抵抗できる力っていうのは誰にもないんです
備わってないんです だからどうやるんですかね
仏道を学んで 実践に挑戦して
抵抗できる力が育つんです
お釈迦様の教えは 完全というのはそういうところなんです
私たちには欲に対立する力はないんです
怒りに対して抵抗する力がないんです
もう独裁者でも支配されています
ブッダの道で この抵抗力がついてくるんです
抵抗力作って作って戦うんです
実践とは 貪瞋痴に真っ向から抵抗することです
仏道の実践とは 貪瞋痴に真っ向から抵抗するんです
例えば これはわかりやすい例で戒律はありますね
で この中でも殺生するなよと
我々は殺生したいんですよ
食べる時でもへっちゃらで殺して食べているんです
それが正しいと思っているんです
殺さなきゃ食べられないでしょうにと
偉そうなことも言うんです
これって存在欲でしょ？抵抗できないでしょ
それでお釈迦様は意図的に殺生するなよと
殺生しないことによって戦っています
我々は欲で物をもらいたいだけなんです
あれも欲しい これも お釈迦様は施し実践しなさいと反対を言っているんです
もらうんじゃなくてあげてみなさいと
あれも本能に対する攻撃なんです
仏道の道徳 戒律 すべて
戒律ぐらいはできそうなんですね
やってみると もう抵抗力が備わってくるんです
仏教にある道徳を守ってみると
結構力が強くなってくるんです
決して簡単な仕事ではありませんね
それでも 本能の反撃 じゃあ
やろうとしても簡単じゃないんです
なんで簡単ではないと言ったのでしょうか
本能が反撃するんです
解脱を目指して精進すると
必ず本能 煩悩が反撃します
例えば お釈迦様の教えを聞いて
では施しを実践しましょうと言っても
これはやっぱり私が欲しいなと思っちゃうんですね
何か活動に寄付金あげようと
1万円あげようとするんだけど 1
万円はどうかな じゃあ 1,000円ぐらいでいいんじゃないか
残りでご飯食っちゃおうと
やっぱりもう反撃しているんです
欲が 存在欲が だからこれは皆様に経験できることで
いいことをしようとしても
どこかで抵抗があるんです
どこかで抵抗が入っているんです
今まで独裁者で命を奴隷にしていたので
自由を認めるわけにはいきませんね
だから貪瞋痴が 煩悩が
本能が我々を独裁しているんです
私たちはただの奴隷なんです
自由がないんです それで私が自由になろうとすると
独裁者がただでは黙っていませんね
反撃します しかし 反撃に怯えると
負けると自由を獲得することはできません
皆様も修行しよう 道徳を守ろうと思っちゃうと
心は抵抗を引き起こすんです
それに負けると もう自由にはなりません
慈悲も実践しようと思ったら
でもあの人はずっと嫌な人間で
私にあれもやった これもやっただから
やっぱりできないと決めるでしょ
慈悲の瞑想すると 嫌な人のことも思い浮かぶんですよ
思い浮かんで怒りがもう反撃するんで
やめなさいよ 慈悲の瞑想と
敵まで嫌な人まで幸せでありますようにと言ったらやばいんじゃないかと
あれ 本能が反撃しているんです
負けたら終わり 独裁者に怯えたら
スーッと奴隷のまま だから対立しなくちゃあかんです
煩悩の前に出て反撃しないと
煩悩ではないと思いますけど
反撃しないと煩悩を滅尽させることもできません
煩悩が 煩悩が前に出て
反撃しないと煩悩を滅尽させることはできません
それで皆様は瞑想しようかな
ブッダの教えをやろうかなと思っちゃうと
邪魔が入るでしょ そうするとみんなこの邪魔さえなければとか思っちゃうでしょうね
心が反撃しないしないんだったら
楽々に修行できるのにとかね
これはそうじゃないんです
瞑想実践始めたら もう嫌なこといっぱい出た方がいいんです
なぜならば 煩悩がもう戦いに来ているんです
戦いに来ているんだから
私たちは攻撃して潰すんです
それで滅尽するんです
煩悩が隠れたままでいたらどうしようもないんですよ
ああ 私は勝利を得た 悟ったと言ったって煩悩があるんだからね
調子に乗った途端現れてくるんです
だから修行中でも戒律を守ろうとしても
道徳をやろうとしても
結構ハンディを感じます
それがいいことで それで戦って打ち勝ったら
自分が成長していくんです
そこで継続力ということは必ず出てきます
仏道を実践すると 貪瞋痴の攻撃を受けます
俗世間的な生き方と同じく
修行をやめたくなります
だから ヴィパッサナー瞑想でもする人々は結構やめたくなるんですよ
30分座る瞑想すると
だいたい二 三百回ぐらいはね
早く終わりたいとかね
やめたいとかね 出てくるんです
そこで継続力ということは必要になるんです
少々頑張っても 悟ったつもりになっても
なってでもやめたくなります
時々 まあちょっとだけ瞑想して
あ これいいでしょうと
いわゆる足が痛くならない程度で
眠くならない程度で ちょこちょこっと瞑想して
あーやったつもりでいる
やってないんです その場合は
あるいは時々いますよ
自分が悟ったつもりになるんです
あれも修行 修行 修行をやめるためなんです
とにかく仏道に本当の目的を目指しちゃうと
やめたくてしょうがないんですよ
それで継続力という問題が出てきます
いくらでも修行をやめる理由
延期する理由があるんです
これはみんな経験があると思いますよ
いくらでも修行しない理由だったらいくらでも出てくる
修行をやめたい理由だったらいくらでもあります
煩悩の攻撃に負けないこと
立ち向かうことが真の継続力と言います
そこでやめたくなってもやめません
煩悩にやられても負けを認めません
立ち向かう この立ち向かう気持ちが継続力というものです
方法というのはいたって簡単です
ただ 現れる煩悩を素直に確認する
心に怒りが出たら これは怒りですと確認するだけ
欲が出たら あ これは欲です
確認するだけ 落ち込んだ
あ これは落ち込みです
興奮になった これは興奮です
これは興奮というものです
これは怒りというものです
これは欲というものです
これは無知ということですと
確認するだけ で 確認することで煩悩が結構負けて負けて下がるんです
煩悩は妄想として現象化して起こるのです
修行する人々にどうやって煩悩が現れるかと
妄想が出てくるでしょう
だから煩悩が妄想家になるんですね
これは妄想として現れるのは全部煩悩なんです
修行中 特にヴィパッサナー実践する人々は
まあ妄想はひどいもんだなとわかっているでしょう
あれが煩悩なんです 潰さなくちゃいかんです
一連の妄想は確認しても消えない場合は
場所を変えたり 修行の仕方を変えたりするんです
例えば ある瞑想瞑想すると
何か変な妄想が入ってなかなか消えない
回転する そうするとちょこっと場所を変えたりするんです
仕方変えたりするんです
例えば 座って修行する人は歩く瞑想にする
それであの一連の妄想がそこでストップになるんです
そういうふうに簡単な方法ですよ
それから常に正しい姿勢を保つ
背筋を伸ばして頭をまっすぐにして椅子でもいるんです
そうすると脳にはエネルギーが入りますから
大脳には活発に活動できます
姿勢崩しちゃうと脳に力がなくなっちゃって
妄想は勝ちます それぐらいの方法で継続力が生まれます
またあります 仏教を学んで理解を深める
とことんブッダの経典をいろいろ学んで
ブッダが教えることに対する理解を深めてみる
慈悲喜捨を実践する 日常生活も修行の一環として行う
掃除 洗濯などなども修行の一環にしておく
心が汚れているだけではなく
影響力もある人間と付き合いを遠慮する
仏教で悪人と交わるなよと言って
悪人というのは悪いことをする人間という意味でもないんです
誰だって悪いことしてるんだから
みんな悪人ですね そうすると付き合う人間なくなっちゃうんです
悪人でありながら影響力もある
そうすると 我々はその悪人の影響を受けちゃうでしょ
それは本当の悪人なんです
その人とは付き合わない
悪いことをしたんだからといって
自分に影響を与えないならば
普通の人間なんです 理性と智慧がある人々と付き合う
社会福祉奉仕なども行ってみる
できる範囲で そういうことで結構煩悩に勝てます
はい それで最後 諦めない継続力を保って
煩悩と戦うことだけは決して諦めてはいけない
で ワーヤ メーテーウ プリソ ナ ニッビン デイエ パンディトという
その意味は 人は努力するべきです
智者は諦めてはならないということですね
理性がある人は諦めてはならない
これはジャータカから
ワーヤ メーテーウ プリソ ヤーワ アッタッサ ニッパダー
ニッパン ソーヴノアット カンタービーヨ ネリッジェティ
意味は目的に それ入れなくちゃいかんだから
達するまで人は努力するべきですと
目的に達するまで努力するべき
お釈迦様は言ってます
結果を出すってこそ輝く有意義になる
だから有意義に努力するでしょ
結果がなかったら輝かないんですね
観念だけなんですね 例えば解脱に達しますと
立派な考えですけどね
すごい有意義で でも結果出さなかったら輝かないんですね
だから結果出すこそ有意義ということは輝くんだよと
それはサンユット二会から
はい そういうことで 仏道を修行すると
貪瞋痴と真っ向から戦うんだから
かなりややこしいんです
貪瞋痴に支配されているんだから
戦いは難しい だから断念する気持ちはしょっちゅう出てくる
その時は前言った方法で断念しないでやり続ける
諦めない ブッダの最初の言葉は決して諦めるものではありませんと
結果出るまでというのがブッダの戒めなんです
はい それで今日の講演を終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます
スマナサーラ先生 ありがとうございます
あの 今高校生なんですけど
大人になるまでにいろんなことをしておきたくて
たくさんの人にこういうことをしたらいいよって聞いてるんですけど
なんかした方がいいと思うことはありますか？ ちょっと聞き取れなかったし
質問が  なんか将来に向けてした方がいいと思うことありますか？ 16歳なんですけど
うん これからしたら人生が良くなっていくよみたいなことってありますか？ あの
大体そんなすごく困らなくても
まあね 普通決まってますから
生き方はね まあ自分にすごく上手にできる勉強をして
もう失敗なくできる仕事の方向へ行って
世の中 あの仕事欲しい
この仕事欲しいではなくて
自分にとってぴったしできることを選んだ方がいいんですよ
仕事の世界では失敗は認めませんだからね
だからたくさん金儲かる仕事を欲しいと思ったっても
これもあんまり意味がないんですよ
すごく楽しく幸せで穏やかで生きられれば十分なんですね
金持ちもむちゃ苦労している場合であるんだからね
大したことないんですよ
だから 一番安全な方法っていうのは
自分が人の役に立つことなんです
それは今からも実践できます
ほんの小さなことでいいんだから
なんとか人の役に立つように生きてみるんですね
お母さん ちょっと助けてあげたり
料理 洗濯 片付けとかね
それやってあげたり 買い物をしてあげたりところから始めたら
どんどんできるようになってくるんですよ
それで友達のことでも
ちょこちょこと何か何か助けてあげたりとかね
そういう人々はいつでも社会のリーダーになるんです
それで自分にとってはすごく気楽になるんです
あの人 私のこと何だか言ってるんじゃないかと
そういうことを消えちゃうんです
誰にも好かれるんです
だから この人を助けるということを始まるんです
今から始まるんです それで人だけじゃなくて
動物であろうか 植物であろうかで助けてあげようという気持ちになると
なんか自分にとってすごい気持ちいい
そうすると勉強もものすごく着々進みます
簡単に理解できるようになります
勉強したものは忘れられないんですね
残るんです 脳の中に だから脳に記憶する技はこの自我を捨てることなんです
自我で凍り固まっちゃうと
この脳の海馬が混乱するんですね
海馬にデータ記録するんです
自我の感情がなくて まあ植物でも助けてあげましょうとかね
動物もまあ何かあったら助けましょうとかね
そういうふうな生き方やってくると自我が減るんですね
それで海馬が健康になるんです
何でも記憶してくれるんです
そこは一番あなたみたいな若い子には
お母さんを助けることから始めたら一番やりやすい
一番やりやすいんです
それはどうってことないことだからね
そこでお母さんどれほど喜んでくれるか自分でわかるんだからね
それからお父さんにもいろいろ協力してあげると
まあ二人とも舞い上がって喜びますよ
そうすると自分としてすごくいいことやってるんだと自信がついてくる
そこはどんどん広げてみるんです
他は心配することは何もないんです
うまくいきます 頑張ってください
ありがとうございました
もう一方あぐらいあって
質問 ちょっと奥の方が先に
真先にね 順番でお願いします
短く質問しますと 仏道では音楽を聴くこと
それは修行の妨げになるでしょうか
うーん 瞑想する場合はやめた方がいいと思いますけど
でない場合は別に問題はないんですね
しかし 音楽を選んだ方がいいんです
心が落ち着く音楽 優しさが生まれてくる音楽
私もすごく感動する曲があって
花はなんでしたっけ？花が咲くってあれあるでしょ
あれ あの あの あの 今度はオリンピックで金メダル取った若い子がね
スケートやりながら曲が全部流れるんですね
私にとってすっごく美しくするんですよ
で これから生まれる君のためというよね
そこでなんとなく優しさ
頑張りましょうということを歌ってるでしょう
だから あの曲とあの子供のスケートを見て
私すごく楽しいんです
じーっと見てるんで 放送する時は
で 自分の心まで明るくなってきて
だからそういう風に歌音楽を選んだ方がいいんですね
激しい怒りやあれやこれや発散する音楽ではもうくたびれちゃいますよ
だから瞑想中は修行中はやめますが
普通は別にそういう風に人格向上する音楽音楽を選ぶということにしてください
はい  ありがとうございました
お話の中で努力は嫌なものだという定義があったと思うんですけども
別の著書でご著書の中で
仕事は簡単にできるぐらいのものはちょうど適したものであると言われていると思うんですけども
努力の中には嫌じゃない努力
喜んでやるような努力というのもあると思っていると受け止めてもいいんでしょうか
それ書いてありましたか？今日の講演で
我々は嫌じゃない 努力っていうのは
本当は全て欲 貪瞋痴から
出てくる努力なんで 例えば音楽が好きでたまらない人は
音楽の練習とかは嫌じゃないんですね
そういうことはあります
しかし 善なる悪にならない努力の場合はなかなかないので嫌になってくるんですね
それから仕事の場合は
できるだけ自分にとって簡単な仕事を選んでくださいと私はいつでも言うんです
カットする仕事を選んではいけませんと
なぜかというと 仕事の世界は真面目な世界で
失敗してはいけない世界なんです
料理人になったら 料理失敗したらもうすべて終わりでしょう
だから失敗を認めない世界
認めないではなくて 失敗はあってはならない世界なんです
電車の操縦する運転手たちが失敗していいわけないでしょう
お医者さんが失敗していいわけないでしょう
だから仕事っていうのは
どんな仕事であっても失敗してはならないんですよ
自分が見栄張ってややこしい仕事を選んだら失敗するでしょう
それは人類に対して危険でしょう
だから仕事を選ぶ場合は簡単な仕事を選ぶと
これも慈しみなんです
それほど勉強できないんだけど
欲を出してとにかく医者になりたいと
頑張って医者になってもうまくいくかどうかわからない
まあ勉強淡々と行って
なんとなく何のことなく振り返ったら医者になってるんだって人には能力あるでしょ
その人にとっては簡単なんですね
だから医者か弁護士か普通のサラリーマンかってのはどうでもいいことで
あなたは淡々と仕事をしているのかっていうことだけポイントなんです
これは世間に対する慈しみなんです
あの 宅急便で荷物運ぶ人々でも失敗したら困るでしょ
だから仕事には上下ないんで
どんな仕事も立派なものなんですね
失敗しないでやってほしい
以上です 何かまだ納得いかないとこある？マイクロフォンに
結局はその世の中分業になってて
例えば音楽だったら その貪瞋痴に基づいた努力が役に立つこともありますよというお話なんですけども
やはり音楽だけをやり続けて
一生を終えて世の中に役に立つこともあると思うんですが
そういった場合 やっぱりその努力っていうのは嫌なものじゃなくて
喜びながらやっていくこともあるという定義でしょうか
自分の努力が人に役に立つと嫌じゃないんですよ
例えばこの震災の時とか
この日本の音楽家 芸術家がみんなそちらに行って歌ったりしたでしょ
その時の歌が普通のレコードで聞くよりはすごくインパクトあるんです
心に伝わるんです 私は聞いたんだからね
なぜならば その場合は
その歌手がお金もらってないんです
自分の能力で人々を慰めてあげようと
それで役に立つんだから
歌も上手に歌える そうすると
自分にはすごく今日の曲を演奏できたなという自信がついてるんだから
自分の次の仕事にもそれがいい影響を与えるんです
だから仕事が嫌じゃない
努力するのは嫌じゃないと
出てくる場合 必ず役に立っていることなんです
で 震災の時はお医者さんたち
看護婦さんたちが飲まず食わず
ずっと寝ない 寝ないで頑張ったんですよ
その時 あの力 どこから来るんですかね
役に立ってるところからなんです
でなきゃ どんな人でも 1 日 24時間仕事したらくたびれるでしょう
でも役に立ってる場合は元気なんです
だから私はサイドで慈しみに入れ替えてくださいと
情動をね 欲を そうするとすごいやる気が出てくるんです
仕事をやる気にならない場合は
これって役に立たないでしょうという時なんです
例えば文章を書く時でも
我々文章を書く人間だから
これは誰も読まないだろうと思っちゃうと書く気が消えちゃうんですよ
誰かが読むでしょうと思っちゃうと
あ しっかり頑張らなくちゃという気持ちが出てくるんです
そういうことです  よくわかりました
ありがとうございます
ちょうど時間になりましたので
ここで修行を終了したいと思います
それでは最後に皆さんで回向の文をお唱えしたいと思います
覚えている方一緒にお願いします
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝帰依し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって 全ての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
では 祝福の経をあげますね
サッティーティヨー ヴィラッジャンツー サンブローゴー ヴィナッソトゥ マートゥエ バワッタンテラーヨー スティー
ディ ガイコー バヴェー アユラーローグャ サンプッティー サッガ サンプッティー メーウェッチェ アトー ニッバ
ーナ サンプッティー ミナハテー サミンギャトゥ
サーリプッタサーリプッタ
どうもありがとうございます